the average car insurance premium could
increase by 75 pounds a year because of
a government ruling that will change the
formula for calculating personal injury
compensation payments currently courts
take two and a half percent from
compensation Awards to reflect the
interest a victim will earn on the lump
sum when they put it in the bank but
because the formula is based on the
interest rate on government bonds which
has now turned negative in real terms
that discount rate is to be cut to minus
point seven five percent meaning
insurers will now pay out significantly
more in lump sums the accountants at pwc
have calculated this could mean young
drivers see their annual premiums rise
by up to 1,000 pounds whereas older
drivers could see there's increase by
300 pounds while the association of
british insurers says the compensation
bill facing the NHS could go up by 1
billion pounds when use of the ruling
hammered the shares of the insurance
companies which say their profits will
be hit massively direct lion closed down
seven percent after it said its pre-tax
profits might be 230 million pounds
lower an admiral shares lost nearly
two-and-a-half percent after it said it
could lose as much as 175 million pounds
and that it was delaying publication of
its annual results Hugh Evans is
directed general of the association of
british insurers and joining us from
Oldham near Manchester is Neil Sugarman
he's president of the Association of
personal injury lawyers will kneel let
me start with you you campaigned for
this change how much of these extra
payouts are going to go into the hands
of personal injury lawyers as opposed to
real victims none none at all this is
all about injured people and we're
talking here specifically about very
seriously injured people who have
life-changing injuries and the point
about these claims is that they relate
to people who will probably never work
again and probably have to be careful
for the rest of their lives and that and
that's why we welcome this announcement
because it's they who are going to
benefit from the Lord Chancellor's
decision so none of your members will be
putting up their rates or anything like
that after these more generous payout
stock coming through the system most
certainly not this is nothing to do with
sisters fees there
predetermined in any event this is a
totally separate topic now given that
this discount rate is set in accordance
with gilt yields government UK
government bonds the latter have been
completely distorted by the bank of
england's asset purchase scheme isn't
this a rather silly way to proceed and
it's about the fact that people who've
been seriously injured tend to be very
risk-averse I've been in practice acting
on behalf of seriously injured people
for 35 years so I'm pretty well placed
to say that people do not want to take
risks with their compensation when they
know it's going to be very important to
their care and they can't readily go out
to obtain income to replace what they've
lost so that's what it's about and I
think we have to respect the fact that
there are vulnerable people and
therefore they have to be very careful
about what they do with the compensation
when it's earned and this is a
reflection of that it's a sensible
reflection of that well Hugh Evans that
that is a fair point i mean this rate
has been at the same level for 16 years
that was a real danger that some
accident victims would go in penniless
they were losing their pet their payouts
and we've never objected to the rate
being reviewed and indeed have supported
calls for the formula to be revised to
deliver a fairer rate we've taken part
in all the government consultations that
has had over many years on this subject
I agree with Neil it's vital that these
claimants get full and fair compensation
and it's very important that they have
lots of options to do so of course one
of the things they can now do which they
didn't used to be able to do is ask the
insurer to manage the money for them to
think something called a periodic
payment order and that is a perfect
option for a claimant who is worried
they may not be able to manage to put
the money properly which has not been
taken account of in the decision reached
today right now of course the government
has just clamped down on whiplash claims
which account for something like half of
all personal injury claims I'm in the
government's in effect take them with
one hand but they've given you back
something with the other haven't they
well I wish the two were evenly balanced
but the impact of today's decision
amounts to many billions of pounds
impacts not just for insurers but as
your introduction noted for the NHS
that's money that could come out of
front-line care and for the Ministry of
Defence and it the reason why this is a
flawed decision is it's based
formula that nobody actually uses none
of the claimants that Neil represents
invest in index little guilt if they do
it they will be losing money hand over
fist which is why Neil would never
advise them to invest in there surely
it's time we have a formula that's based
on how people actually invest in real
life all I knew whatever what do you
what do you make of what you've just
heard from Hugh Evans and I reiterate
that people who've received personal
injury compensation are cautious
investors they have to be and what's
been happening since 2001 is that
they've been in a situation where by
being cautious investors their money as
in some cases run out what does that do
it puts them back having to rely on the
National Health Service and local
authority funding well we all know the
situation in relation to public service
and the stretching of public services at
the moment so we say that the insurance
industry has had plenty of time to
prepare for what's going to happen we
think the approach is a sensible
approach and really with proper
improvement planning we probably
wouldn't be hearing the sort of noises
we're hearing from the insurance
industry today well there's no reason
for anyone's money to run out because I
said they can honestly insure us to
invest that money for them and that's
something that should have been taken
account in these trustees decision today
we all agree there should be a sensible
formula but it has to be one that is
based on how people actually invest
their money and I come back to the point
that this is that we have to have a
formula that reflects that and that
helps people manage their money over the
medium term and that compensates them
adequately there are perfectly
reasonable ways of doing this without
this decision which she's reached today
and to correct Neil we've not had lots
of warning about this this was announced
the stock market on the seventh of
December less than three months ago it's
been done during the closed period when
insurers are preparing for their results
thereby causing maximum chaos for the
sector and this after the Ministry of
Justice has spent the last five years
consulting on this issue without
publishing the responses to any of their
consultations so I don't think anyone
could argue this has been a well handled
process by the Ministry of Justice or
one that has provided certainty to
business I know this is a very important
point isn't I mean all of business right
now needs certainty and a stable
policymaking environment and the
insurance sector certainly hasn't
received that
the association of personal injury
lawyers has been calling on the Lord
Chancellor for six years to do something
about the discount rate 2001 it's 2001
that the rate was last looked at we say
the insurers have had plenty of time to
plan for this but we mustn't lose focus
we're talking about people who are
confined to wheelchairs we're talking
about people who've lost limbs we're
talking about people who have been
severely injured life changing
industries and I'm sorry that's where we
should be focusing not on big business
we are focusing on those we're actually
the people the industry who actually pay
out the claims that enable those people
to live the rest of their life with
dignity and properly cared for so
anything we need any lectures from the
other side about how those people should
be looked after and the importance of
making sure that their payouts matter
that's exactly the debate we've been
engaged in for the last five years but
equally if we're going to perform that
function and ensure for society as a
whole that we have affordable premiums
for motorists particularly for young
drivers who need affordable car
insurance so that they can work as well
as for older drivers to keep them on the
road as long as they wish to be on then
we have to have a balanced system based
on a fair formula and I struggle to see
how the personal injury lawyers can
defend a formula that none of them would
actually advise their members to rely on
what about Neil's points that the sector
has in effect enjoyed some form of
windfall gains during the last 16 years
by the fact that this rate has gone
unchanged for so long well the rate has
gone unchanged for a long time but
that's jus been doing a range of
economic circumstances I don't think
many of our members have enjoyed quite
the windfalls that Neil seems to imagine
but nonetheless we have contributed
through at that time to a constructive
debate about how this could be done
differently we're not people saying
never never don't change a thing we're
saying let's have a formula that's fair
that's balanced that takes account of
the need to provide affordable insurance
right across the economy that provides a
fair deal for claimants and that
critically is based on the way in which
those claimants actually invest their
money not some made-up metric that is 20
years old and that doesn't occupy place
in the real world anymore of course lest
we forget we're about to get an increase
in insurance premium tax from ten
percent to twelve percent is there an
argument for saying that should be put
on hold now while
the system digests these changes well
unfortunately the government put
insurance premium tax up three times in
the last 18 months from six percent to
twelve percent that together with the
increasing cost of car repairs as we're
all driving more expensive cars with
lots of electrics in them and the
increasing cost of whiplash these things
were already driving up motor premiums
before Liz trust his decision so there's
certainly a case for government to act
urgently and what we would like to see
them do is reform the law urgently to
produce the formula that I've argued for
done quickly and fairly so that we can
have a sensible balanced outcome for
everyone